all right so democrats are very
frustrated with this guy joe
manchin uh you've heard this name a lot
this year because they're 50 50. this
the senate is 50 50. there he is and
he's from west virginia
and he's a democrat but he's in a state
that is the trumpiest state in the
nation 69 percent of voters in west
virginia went for donald trump
so we thought this would be a great week
to do 24 things
you didn't know about joe mentioned
because this is one of our signature
things that we completely made up on our
own okay for example uh joe manchin i'm
a democrat except on matters of policy
uh when liberals call me a i
say it's pronounced coke
uh to avoid being branded and elitist i
black out two of my teeth
i always root for the overdog
uh lindsey graham once accused me of
being a closeted republican
i once actually peed on a parade
uh before stopping a coyote from
attacking a child i like to hear the
coyote out
and i wish people would stop saying i
really want to be a republican i don't
but i wouldn't mind being invited to one
of matt gates parties
so there's that is the uh
that is the standard liberal way to look
at joe manchin but there is another way
i know
you of all people are gonna have
something to say about that am i right
yeah joseph of course he's a friend of
mine he's a real democrat and
liberals should love him because he's an
endangered species they should like
build him a
safe nest my party hasn't because he's
because he represents a state with 55
counties because he's not one of which
has voted for a democrat in 12 years
right presidential democrat who won in a
state full of rural white voters right
which they don't have anymore
democrats much less he has he was a
secretary of state before that he has a
real commitment to voting rights he has
a good record as secretary of state
and he's trying to put forward a
proposal that can actually pass
and i i think he's onto something i
think he's i don't think he's ever going
to get 60 you're not going to get 10
republicans
but he's going to die trying and then
there will be i think
an irrefutable case for reforming the
filibuster and passing real voting
rights without the republicans right i
think that's the process to go through
um yeah i mean the democrats have a guy
who votes with them half the time and if
he wasn't there
they'd have a guy who voted like eighty
percent none of it
in baseball this wins against
replacement war right how would your
team do with the average second baseman
rather than you have
joe manchin has the highest wins against
replacement of anybody in american
politics
like i said he's a great guy
you